la menace plane de nouveau sur la
centrale nucléaire de zapporja après que
des tirs d'artillerie ont été lancés
dimanche matin sur le site Moscou et
Kiev s’accuse mutuellement d'avoir
bombardé la zone première version celle
du ministère russe de la Défense les
forces ukrainiennes ont tirées plus
d'une vingtaine d'obus de grands
calibres entre deux blocs énergétiques
samedi et dimanche
toujours selon Moscou le niveau de
radiation reste conforme à la norme le
régime de Kiev ne cesse pas les
provocations afin de créer la menace
d'une catastrophe à la centrale
nucléaire de zaporigia de son côté
l'Ukraine a une fois de plus accusé les
Russes d'organiser un chantage nucléaire
le directeur général de la IEA l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique a
quant à lui dénoncé une situation
totalement inacceptable peu importe le
responsable de puissantes explosion ont
secoué la zone aux aporida la nuit
dernière et aujourd'hui les experts de
l'i-ea signal plus d'une douzaine
d'explosion et certains bâtiments
systèmes et équipements du site sont
endommagés mais jusqu'à présent rien de
très grave faut la sûreté la sécurité
nucléaire dimanche la compagnie
nationale de production d'énergie
nucléaire d'Ukraine energoatom à relever
des dégâts sur certaines infrastructures
de production d'électricité de son côté
zaporigia ciblé par la Méru depuis mars
est officiellement passé sous contrôle
russe en octobre le président Poutine en
avait ensuite revendiqué l'annexion par
un décret depuis plusieurs mois déjà
Moscou et kieve s'accuse mutuellement de
bombarder le site non loin de la ligne
de front
il y a 5